this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck so even if
you're watching this on YouTube the show
is a hundred percent advertisement free
enjoy and minimalists hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
Joshua fields Milburn and my name is
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist Ryan we all know that our
memories aren't in our things our
memories are inside us yet often we hold
on to our material possessions in an
attempt to hold on to our memories and
today we're gonna talk about why we do
this and what we can do to hold on to
our memories without holding on to the
stuff memories a really slippy slippery
thing Ryan I've I realized this when I
was a little kid actually when we were
that we lived in date and we moved 20
miles south to a suburb of Dayton to
this really junky apartment complex but
on the edge of this apartment complex
there was this like wooded area mm-hmm
and as a kid I must have been six years
old at the time about Ella's age and I
wandered out cuz this is back when it
wasn't illegal for children to wander
freely and I was wandering through this
this wooded area Ryan and I came across
the most majestic waterfall hmm in
Warren County Ohio yeah yeah it was
giant I mean it was a gorgeous waterfall
it was majestic yeah and I still
remember it to this day the waterfall
looked like yes I can remember it
vividly because it was so beautiful and
I went back as a young adult and tried
to find this waterfall and of course it
doesn't exist right there might be a
creek back there or some runoff from
sewage I don't know what it was but I
feel like this show is going into a
false memories episode what we are
talking about memories today and I think
that's it's a weird thing like that was
so true to me now what I know I know
that it's not actually there so we
sometimes talk about different types of
truth there are sort of these
these things that we believe to be true
like I believed that walk but I also
know better I know that waterfall
doesn't actually exist right I was
probably as a six-year-old I probably
had a dream yeah and and it was so vivid
especially when you're six like all
these dreams are so vivid you know that
I remembered it as as a real event yeah
and then just recently so this isn't
just a something for kids Beck's and I
were talking about this medication I was
prescribed by a doctor a few years ago
and and she's like how long did you take
that I'm like I remember taking it for
90 days I swore I could've swore you'd
you took it for a couple years I'm like
no I took it for 90 days I'm certain of
it yeah she's like I'm pretty sure and
so I call up Walgreens and I'm like hey
I don't take this prescription anymore
but how long did I take and they're like
yeah it was just over two years Wow
and I I mean I'm certain even now I'm
like no I didn't you know I but I know
that's not true and so the memories are
often things that that we create and
we've got several questions about
memories today also I should probably
say that on the maximal today Ryan I
want to talk to you about Co vid 19 I'm
invincible now I had kovat 90 you're
invincible at least for four months now
it's funny with memories but it makes me
think about the shoe box that I had of
high school stuff during the packing
party uh-huh and how I never opened that
box until I was confronted with all my
things and when I opened it up I was
like why now am i holding on to this but
the memory of the shoe box when I
thought about it it was like nostalgic
took me back and oh yeah there's a cool
shot glass that they gave us for a
senior prom and what other things were
in the box
do you remember some letters that my mom
wrote in high school some pictures of
like me and my high school girlfriend
and I felt you know always felt like she
was the one that got away but when I was
like looking through those memories I'm
like this is not the the thought of the
memories were better than the actual
memories when I confronted that when I
can run through the memories hmm so yeah
I mean to your point of we with our
memories we yeah we we exaggerate them
we make them we make things to be more
than what they are
and yeah it's uh it's it's funny it's
yeah I I don't know again I think this
is going into like a false memory
podcast where we can talk about how you
know you could totally have a memory
that you could pass a lie-detector with
yes but it's it's not but it's actually
not real I think that you could have
given that waterfall lie-detector to me
right now and there's a good chance I
would pass it but I do remember it and
so yeah I do want to talk about memories
we have a bunch of questions from our
audience today so let's go ahead and
dive in the first one today is from
Brittany in Dallas Texas I'm holding
onto things or my daughter she's three
right now and I have things like my
wedding dress they're like I'm thinking
about holding on to in case she wants to
wear it maybe one day when she gets
married what do you guys think about
stuff like that Brittany I've got good
news for you there's not a daughter in
history who wants that who wants their
mother to save their wedding dress and
then wear it later
I've actually there might be one no I've
surveyed world is Facebook I don't think
we should support child abuse on this
show that's a disclaimer yes if you're
gonna save a bunch of stuff for your
kids yeah that is you're not saving for
your kids actually you're saving it for
yourself because what you're thinking is
oh if I was my child then maybe I would
want this and I'm totally obviously
kidding about the child abuse thing I
know that Brittany has the best of
intentions that she wants to pass on
some what it would really call him hair
looms but she was the past lots of
family heirlooms and that is that's
that's the best of intentions but man
like why would you throw a bunch of
stuff on your kids I mean that I can't
tell you how many times we've had people
at our events and they're like I love my
parents left me all this stuff and I
don't know what to do with it I know
that they wanted me to have it but it's
not adding value but I don't want to
hurt their feelings I mean it doesn't I
mean this is happening countless times
yeah we've written about it in in the
book that we've got coming out next year
love people use things
we talked about some sentimental things
that other people have dealt with
outside of us and I think there's a
common theme there Ryan the common theme
is man I hate having to deal with other
people's stuff because I already have
enough of my own stuff to deal with and
when your stuff becomes my stuff I just
have more stuff that I'm forced to
confront now that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't curate some things that we can
pass down to future generations we want
but we also have to realize if we're
gonna pass those things down that they
don't have to accept them and you have
to be okay with that and so as you're
curating these things be really careful
about talking to your kids about what
you're holding on to why you're holding
on to it and letting them understand
letting them know that by the way if you
decide you don't want this
that's fine I'll go ahead and get rid of
it for you so you don't have to deal
with it yes now Ryan you I have have a
few rules we have a actually Brittany
I'm gonna recommend you download the
free ebook and by the way anyone can
download this for free it's over at the
minimalists comm slash rule book it's
called the minimalist rule books sixteen
rules for living with less and I thought
about three of the rules in there Ryan
that really stood out to me that I think
are applicable to Brittany and they all
these three rules sort of tie it
together the first one is the very first
rule we ever came up with and it was the
20/20 rule or we called the just-in-case
rule right and and so what that rule
means is we hold on to many things just
in case we hold on to tens of thousands
of just in case items Oh hold on to that
just the case well I mean what is
Brittany saying right here Ryan I'm
gonna hold on to this wedding dress
just in case my little daughter once it
25 years from now that's quite the
commitment for a just-in-case item yeah
now the problem isn't one wedding dress
if you want on the one wedding dress not
a big deal
doesn't take up a ton of space I mean it
takes up a lot of space but not a ton of
space but the problem is that we justify
that one thing and it's like well hold
on to the wedding dress I should
obviously hold on to this painting or
this portrait or this box of stuff stuff
whatever it is I should hold on to all
these things just in case and we we we
hold on to them not knowing what their
place is going to be in the future it's
just sitting in a box in an attic a
garage a basement a closet a spare
vrooom collecting dust no one's getting
any value think of what do you think
about if Brittany let's say she's got a
wedding dress she's got you know ten
let's say she's got a thousand items who
cares well it's just a thousand wedding
dress a thousand and one wedding dresses
and she really is she has this feeling
of like my kids are gonna want this so
it is a just-in-case type thing what
like when does she approach the child to
say hey I've got this stuff for you do
you want it sure to give them to help
them make a decision to see if they
actually do want it hmm um so if the kid
says no then she can go and get and get
rid of everything cuz that you said that
earlier like that's the key yeah like if
your kids don't want it you gotta get
rid of it like tell you what I would do
I would not I would not approach a
prepubescent kid asking them what words
I should hold on to something to them
that's totally and so if your daughter
is is in 1314 and she's becoming a young
woman and then you can she can start
making those adult decisions around the
things that she might wait is hate to
recommend Brittany hold on to so for 14
years no absolutely not and and that's
why I say there are no there are no kids
who really wish they could have worn
their mothers yeah wedding dress I see
it will frame it and like hang it in the
dining room and like oh that's my
mother's wedding dress yeah but it means
something to them which is great you
know like it does mean something to them
well let's talk about that it means
something to them and by the way I just
I got into a bit of an argument with the
editor of our book because he was
talking about like letting go of
sentimental items and even he has this
problem with with letting go of
sentimental items and he's like well
these things have so much meaning and
I'm like well of course they do they
have whatever but you can say that about
anything right this pen has meeting if
you give it meaning this is from a
podcast studio you could absolutely Josh
Milburn touched this pen but I wouldn't
touch that pin you touched it actually
I'm Co vid free now a pen I'm invincible
Ryan I could have unprotected sex with
anyone and not get Kovan no we'll talk
more about the covet stuff because
actually I suffered with it for about
eight days but we'll go into that later
on the maximal anyway I want to get back
into Brittany here the the question is
what memory
or what memories and what meaning are we
assigning to these items it's very easy
for us to assign it anything is a
sentimental item if we approach it with
sentimentality do something tweet a ball
with that that car the Toyota Corolla
that I finally got rid of yes dude it's
so hard to let go and then I came to the
next day and you're like did you have
the car we should have got rid of in a
certain way I'm like no like do not
bring this back up for me well I wanted
to blow it up yeah like do like a movie
trailer with yeah someone said I should
auctioned it but I actually I would have
felt really bad about selling and maybe
I would have donated it to charity or
something but let's say someone want to
pay me twice when that car is worth just
because it was our car yeah that went on
tour with us yeah I just I wouldn't feel
good about that I mean it was it was
it's at you know in the first
documentary it was it was this thing and
I could so this is actually a really
good example Ryan we assign sentiment
yeah that item there are a lot of
memories that it triggers now that's the
important thing to note here our
memories are not in our things no matter
what you there's no memory in that pin
there's no memory inside this cup but
sometimes they can trigger the memories
are inside us and for your car that
triggers all kinds of memories now
here's the good news about that Ryan we
have endless video footage of us in that
car yeah if we ever want to trigger
those memories we can do that now
someone has someone had a question on on
social media about the what about the
items that require a tactile experience
and you know what I said to that person
give me three examples you know if their
answer was silence crickets the the
thing is there may be something that
requires a tactile experience for you to
remember it but for it to trigger the
memory but quite often that I can't
think of one III absolutely can't think
of one by the way if you can't think of
one leave a comment on YouTube I'd love
to have this conversation with you a
couple other rules before you Brittany
in that rule book that will help I mean
I think all 16 rules will certainly help
you out here they're the rules and
tactics to help you live a simpler life
so we talked about just in case items
what that rule amounts to 20 we call it
the twenty twenty rule anything you get
rid of just in case you can replace for
less than twenty dollars in less than 20
minutes from wherever you are now for me
and Ryan that it's I've used that rule
five times in the last decade so I've
spent about $100
because at first that rule sounds like a
rule of privilege like right oh my god
I'm well you only spend $20 a day yeah I
never just in case on him I need to
replace no the truth is you will get rid
of ten thousand just in case items and
you might have to replace five over the
course of the next decade for me is like
a pair of scissors a potato peeler like
these random things or I'm like I'll
never need that again at a toe peeler
yeah is it just peel potatoes well you
could peel carrots with it too I don't
have a separate peeler for carrots
how many pillars do you have it like
that across good Tim I know I'm OCD but
I like a purple potato peeler a white
potato peeler yes no and so the point is
that hundred dollars gave I spent $100
on this rule over a decade I just can't
believe you spend $20 on a freaking
peeler no I would say less than $20
right and in any way those $100 give me
permission to let go of tens of
thousands of other items so the next
rule is the just for win rule and so we
like to make a difference show a
difference between just in case items
just for win items a just in case item
there's a wedding dress I'm gonna hold
onto this for 14 more years just in case
my daughter wants it 25 years from now
or whatever it might be yeah yeah that's
not gonna be used in a definitive future
there are other items that are just for
win items you don't buy your toilet
paper one square at a time you don't buy
your toothpaste one nurdle at a time
that's the little dab of toothpaste on
your on your on your toothbrush okay uh
nurdle so nurdle and down one units
anonymous interchangeable well yeah it
says it's a more specific word for
toothpaste
it's a nurdle but you wouldn't buy your
toothpaste one nurdle at a time that
would be extremely inconvenient now one
thing about this pandemic Ryan is
forcing us to hoard some things in a
very strange way so I show up to with
the target to buy IND almost out of
paper towels almost out of toilet paper
so I show up right and also I needed up
some like one of the Clorox wipes or
whatever and so I show up there and they
have one option it's a 28 pack of toilet
paper yeah I'm like it's you're asking
me to hoard toilet paper yeah it's
interesting like to
papers coming back but it's all it is
only like one option right yeah that you
have I'm really concerned about your
purely dealer dealer Josh my what your
peeler dealer I'm gonna get you in
contact with my peeler dealer cuz I
think you're getting ripped off on your
peel this man I don't need another one
now just in case or just for when I need
to peel potatoes actually here's the
thing so so I look at both of those
rules the just for win rule just tells
me there are certain things I know I'm
gonna use in a definitive period of time
usually those things fall under what
Ryan then 9090 know which is another
rule that is in that e-book so have I
use this thing as we also called the
seasonality rule have I used this thing
in the last 90 days am I going to use it
again in the next 90 days and if I say
no to both of those things I give myself
permission to let go there's one last
rule that I want to mention here Ryan
and you can check out the rest of the
rules in that free ebook it's the
emergency item rule and so there are
some things there are some just in case
items that I've told myself it's okay to
hold on to having a gas generator in
your closet it just generates gas I
thought podcast Sean was the gas
generator it's it's a joke is like we
would never have a generator but
actually that might be appropriate to
have a generator like possible for
emergencies it's not appropriate for me
but it was appropriate for you great and
so just in case I'm having a first-aid
kit and that's what's great about these
rules it helps you determine what's
appropriate for you there should be the
JAF emerald adjust for Millburn or just
for men yeah just so I know the hair
care company is very mad at my Twitter
handle it's @j FM and I think they
wanted it dude you could sell it to him
not for less than $50,000 no just
kidding so anyway the emergency item
rule tells me that it's okay for me to
have a first-aid kit yeah yeah when we
were in Montana was okay for me to have
jumper cable emergency blanket emergency
plan water flares a semi-automatic
machine just for what I mean just in
case I don't know semiotic sim
semi-automatic machine gun yeah that
doesn't make
yeah no no anyway automatic machine gun
yeah
all right there we go we have another
question here from an in Santa Monica
California my question is about letting
go of parents belongings my father
passed away a few years ago and I was
the executor of his estate and I also
inherited a bunch of things like his
books and certificates and records and
also a large collection of journals that
he had written over the course of his
life I've only looked at three or four
of the journals there you know he had as
we all do and up and down life
experience and I there I have a box of
them and I I don't know what to do with
them I personally would like to let go
of them but there's a part of me that
thinks or my sister also thinks that
there's book material but I don't know
if that's what I want to do with my time
personally so anyway I just wanted to
find out what you thought is I know that
one of you had had experience with
inheriting your parents stuff now Ryan I
thought the first thing and said when
she called in was I want to I'm talking
about letting go of parents which I
thought that's something you could known
them out but then she like had a little
ellipsis there she said parents stuff
and and what we're really talking about
here are sentimental items the first
thing I like to talk about Ryan is
sentimental items if you're if you're
just starting the minimalist journey I
started the wrong way I started with
sentimental items which are the hardest
things to let go of yeah and you don't
have any momentum if you just start with
the most difficult things if you go find
the most difficult thing to get rid of
in your house you're gonna neuro so ver
that forever that's probably the best
place to start but if you've inherited
things from your father mother
grandparents whomever you've inherent
and you've inherited some sentimental
items where you perceived to be
sentimental items you've assigned some
meaning to them but you want to let go
as an wants to do there are some things
that you can do some steps you can take
to to let go yeah and I want you to live
whatever a meaningful life looks like
for you like I want you to do that but
you got to think about some of the
things that we hold on to like it keeps
us stuck in the past
and it's funny because you you're making
the joke about letting go of parents but
they're actually something there and
it's not it's not letting go of your
parents like okay they're out of my life
even with like my dad who doesn't talk
to me I have let the idea of the
relationship I wish we had have let that
go but I still love him and think about
him and uh we got pictures together and
there are some some memories that I
certainly hold on to yeah so you can't
let go of your parents without letting
go of the memories but it made me think
about the the gal who came up to us I
think was in Dallas okay and she her son
had passed away and she talked about how
she hasn't touched his room oh yeah this
was the Barnes & Noble in 2014
yeah I remember it was I mean it was
such a mean talking about it kind of
makes me sad thinking about how she had
she lost her son at you know 14 years
older see I mean it was a tragic thing
yeah when she was talking to us it had
been like five or ten years yeah and she
hadn't touched anything in that room
right it was sort of this this mausoleum
of stuff yeah which again like I I just
want people to live a meaningful life
and if that's what living a meaningful
life for her is then you know
I stole esupport that however I when I
look at it from my perspective if I'm
thinking about me that isn't living the
most meaningful life because it's it's
being stuck in the past
and it's and it's just a constant
reminder of hurt and I think it's so
important to get over the hurt in fact
anyone listen to this who's lost a loved
one
I think they should totally listen to
our pie
guess we did with who is the the yeah
cacciatore yeah yeah dr. cacciatore yeah
I don't know what number that is but
maybe podcast Shawn you put in the
shownotes
Pok has about trauma yeah about trauma
and that's what I mean that's really
what what Anne here is talking about
this trauma that's what the gallon
Dallas was talking about
do I sound old when I say Gao okay so
it's we have to deal with that trauma in
the best way to from again does my
perspective the best way to deal with
trauma is to let go of it as much as you
can so holding onto things that keeps
making you relive that trauma to me that
doesn't sound like a very meaningful
life right yeah I think the holding on
is often clinging right and I think what
you're trying to delineate here is
sometimes there are things that are
worth holding on to
right but sometimes though and actually
I would say most of the time in our
current culture we cling and it's it's
our it's our default almost to cling
yeah now there are reasons there are
sort of evolutionary reasons that we do
this and you can look at our closest
ancestors with chimpanzees and bonobos
and we can explain that in fact I think
we have a question about that for the
the maximal episode but here's what I'll
say to an practically a few things one
and I want to send you copy of our book
everything that remains before I get to
some practical tips for you because if
you're dealing with sentimental items
the there's a whole story in here of me
dealing with my mom's stuff specifically
and and not just dealing with the stuff
but dealing with the sort of trauma
associated with letting go of the stuff
yeah but also realize that you have to
let go of what's weighing you down
before you can move on and that's what
this book and specifically the chapter
about dealing my mom's stuff is about
it's about confronting not just the
stuff but the idea of what that stuff
represents now that doesn't mean there
aren't some things that I would
encourage you to hold on to but in a
different fashion and you you mentioned
the certificates and journals and
records and those are things you might
want to let go of the physical items but
it doesn't mean that you have to
necessarily let go of the the writings
that are in there yeah you can have a
scan
party a couple things you can do there
yeah I would do one of two things one is
have an actual scanning party you can
see the scanner that Ryan and I use the
minimalists comm / scanning we wrote a
whole essay about the scanning party
there and you can feed all your
photographs into it any certificates any
pieces of paper that you want to scan
individually and you invite some friends
over to do that and when you do that you
start realizing that most of these
photos are junk there's no way I want to
retain most of these right some of them
you'll feed through there and you talk
about the memories that they trigger
with other people there and and it's
also important to have a sort of
accountability partner throughout this
someone who's a bit more in neutral yeah
someone you can like relive the memory
like you can talk about the memories
with so thanks it's a fun experience -
exactly and so if I were to bring you
over Ryan you're gonna be less attached
to the my mom's photographs than I would
be attached to them yes and I think the
same is true with journals and
certificates and all of these other
things it's easier to let go of other
people's things absolutely and so a last
thing I'm gonna say here is if you don't
want to do the scanning party there are
services where you can send those
journals to and there's a bunch of them
out there now I know one dollar scan was
one that we used for a while none of
whom are sponsors of ours we don't we
don't obviously do that but you can just
you can google the the different
resources for places that will scan your
basic what you'll do is you'll you'll
send off the journals to them they'll
digitize all of them though they'll
upload them for you though some of them
will even send you on a disk or or
whatever you want and then they can get
rid of the journals for you so you don't
even have to do it deal with it but then
you still have those things that can
trigger the memories without having to
deal with all of the the physical
clutter and then they get rid of the
physical stuff for you which is great
and here's one thing I want to give you
it's gonna take a lot of work to do this
but go get a box and start taking items
out and like do this thought experiment
of how would I feel if this
spontaneously combusted
oh yeah the spot spontaneous combustion
rule yeah and like the thing is is a lot
a lot it's because right now and
struggling well she knows she needs to
let go
that's why she's asking this question
and she's looking for it but she's
looking for I think permission aleko
also she's looking
tools to help her let go so I think this
is a great tool yeah so if if you look
at it and you think oh like it what
would happen to the spontaneously
combusted it will evoke one or two
emotions you'll feel relief or you'll
feel like some dread and yeah I mean
that's a good place to start I'm not
saying that you know you should still
hold on to every single thing that
brings up a little dread anything about
it spontaneously combusting but it'll
help you get rid of some stuff for sure
absolutely and I think what you'll
realize is you'll feel this of this
immense sense of relief with that rule
that that's one of the rules in the the
16 rules for living with less free ebook
that you can download as well so and
we're gonna send you a copy of
everything that remains if you want the
audiobook version if you like our
podcast I think you'll love the
audiobook version or if you want the
book book or the ebook we're happy to
send those to you as well also since you
are in Los Angeles County we rescheduled
our entire les Coast tour for November
and I can't wait to do it and get out
there and it's our first tour in two
years we've got some amazing special
guests on this tour 16 special guests in
total musical guest podcast gasps we're
going to talk about creativity and
minimalism and simplifying and how
creativity impacts every area of our
life if you want to find all of our tour
dates you can find those over at the
minimalists comm slash tour if you don't
see your city on there just sign up for
our email list we'll let you know when
we're coming to a city near you so and
I'll give you a couple a couple tickets
to our tour stop in November in Los
Angeles Ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it it's time for our
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to nine three
seven two zero two four six five four
yes indeed those texts go straight to
both of our phones and we personally
reply to as many as we can we tried
something just recently Ryan I don't
know if you saw all the response to this
but there must've been a hundred people
the text yesterday because we asked we
just went out on social media and said
hey and I'd love to offer this to the
podcast audience as well because it was
such a fun little experiment text us a
emoji of the most recent thing that you
decluttered hmm and so get creative with
this so what's the most recent thing
that you declutter in people were I mean
you glasses
and I mean I glasses and and eggplants
or a lot of eggplants people's getting
rid of the eggplants like crazy Ryan but
now if you Texas 9:37 two oh two four
six five four we will respond to you
personally at least to as many people as
we can also we'll add you to our Monday
morning minimal maximum so every Monday
we start your week off with a little bit
of simple living advice a Monday morning
minimal maximum to you of course will
never send you spam or junk or or
advertisements or anything like that
Ryan what uh what question we got we got
a question for Mona I have a small box
that contains old letters and photos
that I cannot throw away should I
establish a rule that says I can have
this little box but nothing more I mean
I kind of like that rule the the problem
is sometimes you might need more than
what's in that box
right and and then sometimes what's in
that box might be too much as well
what's in the box yeah I mean I would
have decluttered that for sure no so if
I look at if I look at setting up a rule
like that
the problem with rules and we even
acknowledge us in the minimal rule book
is rules are arbitrary and sometimes
they're boring but sometimes they're
helpful but be willing to adjust those
rules accordingly identifying what is
enough for you right now in that box
might be enough for you but in the
future it might be too much and so my
pity as the material possessions aren't
the problem our attachment is the
problem I've got one more pithy answer
for you it's just three words attachment
is suffering sounds like something a
Buddha would say right I mean there's
something in there like I don't know if
it's a there's some Buddhist equivalent
to that but there's something about
attachment that really does and in fact
again I got to another argument with our
editor because he's talking about like
you know one of the rules I live my life
by is my willingness to walk away yeah
from anything including the people
closest to me yeah and he was just I
mean in fact his notes on this were like
I hate this section and I'm like well
it's the rule it's the if I were to pick
one rule that I live my life by it's
this rule yeah it's one of the rules in
the rulebook but it's it's a willingness
to walk away from anything
actually strengthens my relationships
because what is what is the the opposite
its pious placation it's like well I I
guess I'm obligated to be with you riot
and so I have to show up here every -
who wants to do that I would rather what
I want to show I look forward to showing
up and seeing you on Tuesdays when we
record these yeah and and that's better
than being like well I guess we have to
I have to be in this relationship or I
have to do this no and by the way I got
this rule from two places one is a
negative is a visualization that the
Stoics talk about where they talk about
what's the sort of worst thing that
could happen well yeah you could die
today Ryan and so I that that making me
visualize that makes me appreciate the
fact that you're here so much more and
then also the movie heat when Robert De
Niro's character Neil McCauley it was
like never bring anything into your life
that you're you're not willing to walk
away from in 30 seconds flat
yeah and well III I don't say I would
walk away from anything in 30 seconds
flat I do think it a willingness to walk
away from anything means that you you
really maintain the things that are
truly important than my life feel like
it's a superpower yeah yeah yeah call
one to maintain yeah um you know I
before I read might put the answer here
it makes me think about my car and how
if I really try to Drudge up the memory
and like think about letting that car
okay it could still be painful sure so
it doesn't mean that's easy right but
after you know doing this for however
many years we've been doing this I can
let go of something and and and not sit
there in a row so over it my path answer
is this make rules for yourself only if
they help you be a better person so Mona
that's what it comes down to right like
what is gonna help you be a better
person is it the one box of stuff is it
two boxes of stuff is it a storage
locker full of stuff it's probably not
the ladder but that's the question that
is a ladder everyone's got a ladder you
don't have a ladder no you need a ladder
dealer
grandma Ethel Bob mites my six - just in
case I actually got rid of a ladder but
I'm really tall so yeah that's true you
don't need a letter um yeah I mean
that's the question that Mona needs to
ask or anyone else listening to this you
have having trouble of letting go of
things is what's gonna help you be a
better person all right well before we
get into our added value segment Ryan
which I think we're gonna like today and
our listener tips which are really good
today as well we have a bunch more
surprise questions and a bunch of other
things to talk about this week like I
get this whole minimalist thing but I
got so many questions but but there was
like this controversy around sentimental
items like we're mean or cruel or rude
or awful people or terrible human beings
crazy projections because this is about
these are our opinions yeah yeah this is
this is an op-ed we've been doing a
10-year op-ed so we're gonna address
some of these controversies as well also
um what do we do with sentimental items
that were gifted to us and we're gonna
discuss 7 questions to help you let go
of sentimental items plus we'll answer a
bunch more questions and criticisms we
received this week also backs and I both
tested positive for Cove vid 19 we're
gonna talk about that and if you want to
hear all that let's let's listen to this
week's maximal episode on the minimalist
private podcast it's just a couple bucks
and it's the most honest way for this
podcast to earn an income because you
know we don't believe in advertisements
advertisements sucks so we make money
only if you find value in and support
what we create thank you so much if you
are a supporter of this podcast head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
support to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app Ryan what else you got for us this
week here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners check them
out I'm calling regard to those who
asked about their camping gear and
having all that stuff like in their
house and why to minimize it one option
that makes having long G is the urban
ecology Center it's a non-profit
and this group you donate $35 a year as
a single person and it really just goes
towards keeping on top it going they try
and get community involvement and
education around the environment and
preserve the wildlife wasn't long me but
the awesome thing about them is that
they offer free camping gear and kayaks
and Mike's like anything that you want
to rent you can write for up to three
days or longer you get initial request
I'm sure they're not the only city that
there's a option like this out there so
just let me to keep in mind that there
might even like community groups in the
area that helped you have access to
those items but I have to have them in
your own home hi this is Stephanie from
Maine I started minimizing earlier this
year when I was pregnant my son is now
six months old after much deliberation I
decided to start a small memory box for
him as I have enjoyed having some items
for my childhood growing up and this may
add value to his life at some point I
will save a few items such as his
hospital bracelet birth announcement and
a baby outfit as he gets older he can
decide if he wants to contribute any
items to his box but any saved items
have to fit in the bin the important
thing is that I don't attach sentiment
to these items and project my own
emotions on my son he will decide what
adds value when he is an adult you can
choose to keep some all or no items I
will allow him to make this choice with
no guilt or expectation on my part
alright y'all for our added value this
week Ryan you've seen better call so all
right god have you seen the fifth season
yet yeah I just finished it now now
here's here's why I I've been watching
good now Bex and I are rewatching well
I'm rewatching Bex had never seen
Breaking Bad and so I like better call
Saul better than Breaking Bad that's
exactly what I was going to sum okay
Breaking Bad is considered like this
classic TV show one of the top five of
all time took me a season and a half to
get into and the only reason I watch it
is because I broke my back and I
couldn't do anything but be in bed for
those six weeks breaking backs
breaking back school yeah and I was like
I'm gonna see her watch Breaking Bad and
I had already watched it for a season so
I started with season two and I got into
it I'm like oh like I could see yeah but
it starts coming together
but here's here's the seasons here's the
freakin arc of Breaking Bad though uh
you know Walter White does something
good
Jesse screws it up Walter White has to
fix it and then it's just like eight
seasons of that well I mean I yes I
think it's five see or five that's a
weird thing so better call Saul is five
seasons in now right and so the reason
I'm recommending it right now I knew you
had seen Breaking Bad and I didn't know
about a better call so I think better
call Saul is a better film I'm really
glad they filmed it in Albuquerque
because Albuquerque's Albuquerque sort
of becomes one of the characters or
character of this you know that episode
and better call Saul in the desert
I have never I had to like go drink
water because I was thirsty yes for like
they do that is such a it is so well
directed and the other the filming is
beautiful and yeah again like it made me
feel like I was in the desert with them
it was it was crazy if you've never been
to New Mexico it's the only way I can
describe this guy there it's not like
any of the other states around it even
even though the state's around it are
beautiful but New Mexico there the sky
is like in Technicolor HD it's it's a
different sky and really Mexico in
particular yeah Santa Fe and Albuquerque
and the surrounding areas it's been
several years since we've been there we
filmed part of our first documentary
minimalism in Albuquerque yeah and and
there's something about that that state
that I just I really enjoy there's
there's an essence there and they
capture it really well and Breaking Bad
but better call Saul is the show that I
think Vince Gilligan the show creator
he's given some leeway because there's
some things you couldn't do if you were
just a new showrunner
type of person because you you wouldn't
be given that leeway to have these long
pauses and these drawn-out moments of
tension that really creates I mean it's
and the way the cameras are most of them
are are handheld I know Jordan's totally
adverse to holding a camera in his hand
but it's like a union rule or something
but there's something about the the the
the shots in that show and Jordan could
actually tell me a whole lot more about
it than than I even know but a lot of
the shots are that it's handheld even
they're around a conference table you
see there's this slight shaking and and
there's something about it there
this essence is rawness in any way
better better call so I just finished
the fifth season Max and I are in the
middle of watching I think we're in the
third season
I can't binge anything I get really
tired at night yeah so me binging is
like one and a half episode so it takes
us months and months and months to
finish the show but we've been watching
it and I got confused because I was
watching better call Saul and I'm like
have you been introduced to this
character and and because it happens in
the same universe but better call Saul
could just be called Breaking Bad -
because it is the story of of Jimmy
Jimmy going from bat good too bad he's
Breaking Bad right and and really that
you see that in all these characters and
what it made me realize Ryan is we we
all have that capacity we're all several
decisions away from being Walter White
right oh yeah sure and maybe it's not us
cooking meth right uh but there's this
podcast I sent you with I'm trying to
get Matt Cox on the podcast he like
committed all this sort of mortgage
fraud back in the the Oddie's and it's
the most he's like the James Bond of
mortgage fraud huh and Rob's telling
backs is like look I'm two decisions
away from being Matt Cox and going to
prison for 20 years or whatever late not
because that's something I would do now
but he made two additional bad decisions
that I didn't make and so we're all this
amalgam of good and bad and I try to
write about this in the new book we have
coming out where you know there's a
whole chapter about telling the truth
and and some of the trouble you and I
got into in our teens and 20s and and
and it allows us in a way to have
compassion for other people because you
and I aren't perfect and I think that's
what I want people to get out of this
whole episode we're talking about
memories you and I have held onto things
for a long time we decided to let go too
late we clung to things for far too long
and the future there'll be things that
we accidentally cling to and we have to
we have to check ourselves we're still
imperfect but it's about making those
good decisions today and tomorrow and
going forward because you you alluded
this earlier around we can't go back and
change the past and we certainly
shouldn't cling to that past either
it wasn't until season five of better
call Saul that I realized Saul Goodman
was Saul good man
it took me ten seasons of this to
realize what his name was
yeah like what it meant yet also uh our
friend Lee DeWyze Ryan's friend Lee
DeWyze had he's a very talented musician
has a new song out do you remember the
name of it
oh my heat man I even got his record he
sent me a rye signed record I think it's
victims of the night it is it is you
know memories
it is victims of the night yeah oh yeah
right I have a photogenic memory you do
man you do you know I think it's not
photographic but it looks really good in
photos am i minimalist if I get a record
player
no it's rule number 17 actually so Sean
you can't yell with us for this if we
play out with Lee DeWyze well he's given
us permission to play it right we even
have the email from him and so let's
play out today at the very end of this
episode with Lee DeWyze of song victims
of the night it's a really good brand
new song from Lee DeWyze real quick four
right here right now here's one thing
that's going on life of the minimalist a
new month is right around the corner
it's almost here and of course that
means a new opportunity to play the 30
day minimalism game you can download the
30-day minimalism game calendar it's a
free calendar over at the minimalists
comm slash game if you don't know how
the game works i'm not gonna explain it
to you right now just check it out over
there the minimalists comm slash game
join tens of thousands of other people
who are sharing their photos online
they're getting rid of stuff throughout
the month and whoever plays the longest
throughout the month wins check it out
the minimalistic calm slash game
download your free calendar over there
as well tell them what they win Josh a
set of steak knives riot third prize is
you're fired
all right you can follow the minimalists
on facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalists if you have a question
comment or minimalism tip for our
podcast email a voice memo to podcasts
at the minimalists comm comment on this
episode youtube.com slash the
minimalists if you want our show notes
in your inbox sign up for our e-mail
list over at the minimalists comm you'll
also get our simple Sunday emails and if
you leave here today with just one
message we help us this love people and
use things because the opposite never
works thanks for listening we'll see you
next time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]